bonjour alors d'abord je voudrais vous
souhaiter à tous une bonne rentrée je
sais que ça fait un petit moment depuis
ma dernière vidéo et ça repousse par
tous aujourd'hui je vais utiliser un
format court pour revenir un petit peu
sur la notion de structuralisme en
revoyant la vidéo sur game of thrones je
me suis aperçu que j'étais pas vraiment
très clair sur ce qu'était le
structuralisme et sur ce que ça
impliquait dans notre vie de tous les
jours c'est pour ça que je vous propose
un petit adam doom sur le structuralisme
alors évidemment c'est pas mal si vous
avez déjà vu la vidéo sur game of
thrones parce que je vais reprendre pas
mal de points que j'avais abordé dans
cette vidéo là mais cette vidéo peut se
regarder de façon complètement
indépendante aussi un fatah vous faites
comme vous voulez bon pour reprendre un
peu depuis le début le structuralisme
considère que l'individu est déterminé
par un certain nombre de structures qui
vont profondément influencé sa façon de
voir de pensée et donc de se comporter
du coup basiquement pour comprendre ce
que c'est que la pensée structuraliste
il faut comprendre ce que c'est une
structure on peut définir les structures
comme toutes les instances de
socialisation à laquelle on est
confronté typiquement l'école la
religion la famille sont autant de
structures qui vont déterminer en
profondeur notre façon de voir le monde
bon ça à la limite ok mais ce qui va
falloir regarder maintenant ces quelques
exemples de ces structures pour voir
belle comment ils agissent et comment
elles nous font agir dans la vie de tous
les jours prenons l'école par exemple
c'est une institution qui existe dans la
plupart des pays
et pourtant elle n'aura pas les mêmes
impacts sur la socialisation en fonction
de son mode de fonctionnement par
exemple en france on est habitué depuis
tout petits à recevoir des notes alors
vous ne le savez peut-être pas mais il
ya beaucoup de débats en sciences de
l'éducation sur la pertinence de la
notation
la question c'est juste est ce que les
notes sont ou non un bon système
d'évaluation pour parce que normalement
la note elle est juste censé refléter
notre apprentissage
on a une bonne note si on a compris et
une mauvaise note sur n'a pas compris
bon mais du coup entre celui qui a sept
et demi sur 10 et celui qui à 8 sur 10
est-ce qu'on ne pourrait pas dire qu'ils
ont tous les deux bien compris quand
même
où se fait la différence et c'est là
qu'on voit ce qu'induit la structure
d'un système de notes les notes ne sont
pas faites pour refléter les
apprentissages mais pour créer de la
compétition parce que si on voulait
juste refléter le niveau d'apprentissage
on dirait il a compris il a moyens
compris où il a pas compris et puis
basta
mais là non on est noté lui la 8 lui il
a eu neuf lui il ya eu neuf et demi et
du coup comme ça on met les élèves en
compétition les uns avec les autres et
le but de la notation c'est de créer des
meilleurs et des moins bons et donc on
élargissant le spectre la notation
participe de faire de la scolarité une
culture agonistique qui point de
vocabulaire agonistique ça vient du mot
grec
agon qui veut dire compétition donc une
culture agonistique c'est une culture de
la lutte une culture du combat je vous
le donne ses cadeaux c'est pour vous la
péter en dîners mondains
bon après ces éléments il soit aussi
alimenté par un autre débat qui porte
plus maintenant sur la pertinence même
des notes à travers des mécanismes qui
sont bien connus en sciences de
l'éducation comme l'effet cloche ou la
conscience macabre alors l'effet cloche
c'est l'effet qui fait que un professeur
qui corrige les copies il va toujours
avoir la même répartition des notes dans
sa classe va y avoir très peu de très
bonnes copies une grosse masse à la
moyenne autour de 10 et très peu de
mauvaise copie et la conscience ma cave
c'est un corollaire qui dit qu'en fait
on retrouve les faits cloche quelle que
soit la composition de la classe c'est à
dire que si tu munich l'as où tu prends
que des premiers de la classe qu'avec
que des vins dans leurs classes
respectives et qui les met tous dans une
même classe quand le prof va corriger
des copies et ben la conscience macabre
dit que y aura toujours un petit nombre
de très bonnes copies une grosse masse
au milieu il ya un petit nombre de
petites notes et ça ce phénomène il est
très connu
demandez à n'importe qui qui soit allé
dans une grande classe préparatoire où
il n'y a que des bons élèves
bon bah y'en a qui se retrouve un cinglé
moyenne parce que le but de cette
institution s'est créé de la différence
c'est de créer de la compétition et du
coup il ya d'autres problèmes qui
naissent du fait qu'on utilise un
système de notation qui ne reflète pas
la qualité réelle du travail de l'élève
ça en corse et les phénomènes très connu
mais on sait qu'un élève qui reçoit
plusieurs mauvaises notes va se
considérait lui-même comme un mauvais
élève et donc va adopter les
comportements qu'on attendrait d'un
mauvais élèves et donc va rentrer dans
un cercle vicieux qui va qui va faire
que ses notes vont continuer à baisser
qui va continuer à s'identifier pendant
vos élèves et peut-être à terme être
éjecté du système scolaire
alors qu'en fait à la base il avait
peut-être complètement les capacités
pour réussir
bon ben là on a typiquement un exemple
des effets que peut avoir une structure
dans la vie réelle de fait il
existe plein de systèmes d'enseignement
plein de systèmes d'évaluation
différents et la notation n'est pas une
fatalité et on voit que la notation
provoque du conflit il ya certes un
système scolaire comme en finlande où on
a complètement abandonné la notation est
même l'évaluation ne fait que de
l'apprentissage
et bizarrement ils sont premiers de
toutes les enquêtes sur l'éducation
bon mais étudier les structures de notes
c'est un peu le niveau 1.0 d'année
surtout réaliste parce que là on voit
clairement où est la structure on peut
la comparer avec les autres
c'est assez facile ce qui est plus
compliqué avec les structures sociales
c'est que le plus souvent elles sont
complètement intériorisé si bien qu'on
ne les voit plus qu'elle nous paraissent
presque naturel et pour parler de ça je
vais prendre l'exemple du patriarcat
alors le patriarcat c'est un mode
d'organisation de la société entre
parenthèses de notre société basée
autour du fait que la descendance se
fait autour de l'homme le mal va donner
son nom à son fils et tout s'organise
autour de la personne masculine de la
famille alors ça c'est la définition de
base y a plusieurs effets qui vont dans
nos sociétés plutôt se traduire par de
la misogynie par la discrimination
sexuelle par un rabaissement du rôle des
femmes et par la valorisation du rôle de
l'homme de la virilité du masculin et
plus généralement sa irrigue la pensée
selon laquelle le masculin est viril
compétitif et violent et le féminin est
doué mans et coopératif hélas ce qui va
être dangereux avec ses structures très
structurante sait qu'on va avoir
tendance à vouloir les essentialiser à
les naturalisés et on a tous déjà
entendu des discours visant à
naturaliser les rapports de genre vous
savez ce genre de discours qui commence
pas oui mais voilà c'est parce qu'autour
des hommes préhistoriques l'homme il
partait à la chasse c'est pour ça qu'il
est plus fort et que du coup ils
agressif il fait de la compétition alors
que du coup on fait les femmes comme
elles sont enceintes et bakel font des
bébés
du coup elles sont occupées puis elle
soir à la maison et puis c'est pour ça
qu'elles sont moins payés trop pressés
pour avoir un raisonnement argumenté
vous aussi faites appel à jean-michel
raccourcis ça c'est du gros boggis de sa
mère bon pour simplifier au maximum
l'essentialisation là ce serait de dire
que naturellement le masculin est
agressif et compétitif et le féminin est
doux et coopératif alors pour cet
exemple je vais m'appuyer sur le travail
du nord
prologue qui s'appelle marguerite mid et
qui en 1933 a publié son enquête
anthropologique qui a été traduit en
français par moeurs et sexualité en
océanie et ce qu'elle montre c'est que
les notions d'agressivité ou de douceur
associés à chacun des genres ne sont pas
naturelles mais socialement construite
puisque elle a pu observer des sociétés
dans lesquelles les hommes étaient doués
coopératif et les femmes compétitives et
agressives en fait le mieux pour faire
apparaître visuellement la structure
sociale ça va être de les mettre dans un
petit tableau pour chacun des genres on
a donc deux types de comportement ils
peuvent être soit doux sois agressif et
bien elle montre que l'on peut remplir
chacune de ces cases puisque chez les
champs bulli ce sont les hommes qui sont
doués les femmes qui sont agressives
linverse donc des sociétés occidentales
mais on trouve aussi des sociétés où les
deux genres sont doux et coopère comme
les haras pêche de nouvelle guinée où
d'autres où les deux sont agressifs
comme c'est le cas des mines de bowmore
et du coup c'est vrai que l'art
présentées sous forme de tableaux on la
voit bien apparaître la structure
sociale et on voit que va effectivement
elle n'est pas donnée
en fait ce tableau nous apprendre deux
choses déjà que ben notre structure
sociale n'est pas la seule possible et
surtout bas que quelle que soit la
nouvelle société qu'on va étudier
a priori on pourra la faire rentrer
quelque part dans le tableau et que les
possibilités de réagencement ne sont pas
infinies puisqu'en fait on a fait toutes
les combinaisons possibles
en fait c'est aussi ça qui essaie de
montrer le structuralisme et que j'avais
abordé avec la métaphore du jeu de
cartes
c'est que en fait dans chacune des
sociétés il ya des espèces de
superstructure qu'on retrouve partout
alors ce qu'on va retrouver partout
c'est typiquement pâle le patriarcat
mais le fait qu'il ya une forme
d'organisation genre et de la société
est en fait voilà le structuralisme ça
sert à ça ça sert à simplifier la
compréhension d'un mode d'organisation
pour pouvoir comparer des sociétés entre
elles voilà donc j'espère que j'ai été
suffisamment clair il est général c'est
que le patriarcat n'est pas une fatalité
et qu'il ya plein de façons d'inventer
les rapports de genre dans une société
bon et maintenant il ya un dernier point
sur lequel j'aimerais insister c'est le
langage safely dans ma dernière vidéo
que le structuralisme à la base il était
de la linguistique
donc du coup bah pourquoi le langage
c'est si important au structuralisme et
bien parce que le langage c'est une
structure et c'est même l'une des toutes
premières structures à laquelle on est
confronté alors c'est une chose dont on
parle est extrêmement bien franck lepage
dans sa conférence gesticulée alors bon
la conférence fait cinq heures et vous
dit pas forcément de la regarder en
entier même si en fait vous pouvez y
aller c'est tellement passionnant je
vous mettrai dans la description de tels
codes à partir de quand regarder mais
bon pour résumer son propos il explique
les choses comme ça on pense avec des
mots les idées elle n'existe pas comme
ça en l'air de façon intérêts pour
réussir allait réfléchir il faut les
mettre en mots et si on m'enlève un mot
ou un concept je vais avoir eu
énormément de mal à penser cette chose
où ce concept c'est exactement ce qu'on
avait vu dans la vidéo dans game of
thrones avec l'impossibilité de khal
drogo de penser le concept e tron
parce que le mot trône n'existe pas dans
la langue de d'autres acquis après il va
encore plus grand en entrant le pouvoir
que peuvent avoir les mots et il montre
en fait que la prérogative du pouvoir en
place du gouvernement mais en fait ça a
toujours été celle de nommer les choses
par exemple dans les années 60 tout
moment de mai 68 il ya un mot qu'on
utilise est quasiment tout le temps et
qui a complètement disparu aujourd'hui
c'est le mot exploiter et ce mot est
porteur de sens parce que quand on
entend un exploité tout de suite on va
chercher un exploiteur responsable et on
va essayer de se retourner contre
l'identité
alors que maintenant le ski a été très
fort ce qu'a réussi à faire le pouvoir
s'était de remplacer le mot exploité par
le mot défavorisés et là bas tout de
suite ça suppose pas du tout les mêmes
choses parce que donc exploiter c'est un
processus on va chercher l'exploiteur
défavorisés c'est un état c'est à dire
que on va pas chercher un des favoris
thater le mot existe même pas donc du
coup on voit bien ce qui change notre
façon de comprendre la même situation en
fonction du mot qu'on utilise
c'est le même mec dans la même situation
mais alors dans un cas il a été exploité
pin par quelqu'un dans l'autre il a pas
une pole
moi quand même pas le faire chier le
medef parce que ce qu'on a pas de pot je
vais finir par une dernière occurrence
sur les querelles de vocabulaire je sais
pas si vous vous souvenez c'était en
2012 il ya une loi qui est passée visant
à supprimer la case mademoiselle dans
les formulaires administratifs
bon bah quand la loi est passée y en a
plein qui trouvait que c'était une bonne
chose la plainte qui trouvait que
c'était un appauvrissement regrettable
langue française y en a plein qui sont
tamponnés lauriers avec une babouche
aussi pour ceux qui n'avaient pas suivi
pourquoi on supprime la case
mademoiselle des formulaires
administratifs
déjà parce que c'est une question
intrusive en fait on demande de choisir
entre madame mademoiselle donc on
demande si elle est mariée ou s'élève à
marier c'est vrai qu'à la limite ça
poserait moins de problèmes s'il y avait
une case monsieur et damoiseaux mais bon
le mot damoiseaux lui il est
complètement tombé en désuétude et là il
ya personne pour gueuler contre
l'appauvrissement la langue française en
est quand on regarde à la lumière de la
structure que le patriarcat le mot
mademoiselle ça signifie quoi
eh ben ça signifie que une femme n'est
pas une personne parce que soit elle et
mademoiselle sous l'autorité de son père
soit elle et madame sous l'autorité de
son mari est pas une personne à part
entière et du coup ce mot renvoie à une
époque où les femmes n'étaient que des
citoyens de seconde zone et qu'ils ne
pouvaient rien faire sans l'autorisation
de leur mari
non parce qu on a tendance à l'oublier
mais c'était y'a pas longtemps ma grand
mère quand elle est née elle n'avait pas
le droit de vote et jusqu'en 1965 elle
n'avait pas le droit de travailler ou
d'ouvrir un compte en banque sans
l'autorisation de son mari je mettrais
un lien dans la description sur la
chronologie de gros des femmes juste
pour mais pour en revenir à la
suppression de la case mademoiselle la
grande majorité des gens c'était quand
même ceux qui sont tapés la quiche en
clairement et là l'argument qu'on a
beaucoup entendu mais d'ailleurs qu'on
entend quasiment tout le temps dès qu'il
ya des revendications féministes sur des
petits points comme ça c'est
sérieusement vous n'avez que ça à faire
et pas des choses plus importantes du
genre je sais pas les inégalités de
salaires voilà typiquement cet argument
va falloir arrêter parce que justement
on n'est pas en train de pinailler quand
on s'attaque au vocabulaire quand on
certain que vocabulaire en fait on
s'attaque à la structure parce que comme
je viens de vous l'expliquer le langage
c'est un des éléments qui nous permet de
penser la société
donc si on parle avec un langage
patriarcale et discriminatoire
on va produire une société patriarcale
et discriminatoire parce qu'on sait très
bien qu'il suffit pas qu'une loi soit
votée pour qu'elle soit respectée
encore faut-il qu'elle soit passée dans
l'habitude social de la société
je finirai donc là dessus faites
attention à ce que vous dites parce que
tout est porteur de sens alors cet
épisode est maintenant terminée j'espère
qu'il vous aura plu
je profite de la fin de cet épisode pour
faire deux trois petites annonces
général alors vous avez dû remarquer que
je sors pas d'épisode très souvent c'est
parce que ça me prend énormément de
temps à faire et il se trouve que là
cette année j'ai une formation qui va
nous demander beaucoup de temps donc je
vais avoir encore moins de temps pour
faire des vidéos donc je vais essayer de
faire le maximum mais voilà ce sera à
géométrie variable je peux rien vous
promettre sur les publications que je
pourrais faire cette année pour ceux qui
se demandaient non le format
sociologique n'est pas terminée j'ai
encore plein d'idées à faire place à des
émissions de sociologique c'est juste
que pour l'instant les formats plus
courts sont peut-être plus approprié à
mon emploi du temps mais vous inquiétez
pas les formats longs vont revenir donc
bien prenez soin de vous et puis à la
prochaine